This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. All of us have days when despite our best efforts, everything just goes wrong. Sometimes terribly wrong. It was a devastating problem. Atul Gawande is a surgeon at Brighamon Women's Hospital in Boston. He's also a writer. You might have read his work in the New Yorker or in Slate. A few years ago, Atul was at work, operating on a patient he refers to as Mr. Hagueman.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。我们所有人都有过这样的日子：尽管我们付出了最大的努力，但所有事情还是都出了岔子。有时甚至是糟透了。这是一个令人痛心的难题。阿图尔·加万德是波士顿布莱根妇女医院的一名外科医生。他同时也是一名作家。你可能在《纽约客》或《Slate》杂志上读过他的文章。几年前，阿图尔在工作中为一位他称之为哈古曼先生的病人做手术。
I was taking out a tumor of the adrenal gland laparoscopically. He'd performed this procedure dozens of times before, but this time was particularly tricky. Mr. Hagueman's tumor was behind his liver nestled tightly against an important blood vessel. The main blood vessel returning the blood of the body to the heart. It's known as the Vena Keva. Atul began the surgery and everything was going smoothly. He was almost done detaching the tumor when all of a sudden he nicked the blood vessel. I ended up creating a hole in the Vena Kava, which meant that he then pretty quickly lost his entire blood volume into his abdomen, complete blackout on the screen and utter chaos.
我正在用腹腔镜切除一处肾上腺肿瘤。他以前做过几十次这种手术，但这次格外棘手。哈古曼先生的肿瘤长在肝脏后面，紧紧贴着一条重要的血管。那是将全身血液输送回心脏的主血管。它被称为下腔静脉。阿图尔开始做手术，一切都进展顺利。他快要把肿瘤剥离下来时，突然间，他刮破了那条血管。我最终在下腔静脉上弄出了一个洞，这意味着他的全身血液随后很快就流光到了腹腔里，监视器屏幕上一片漆黑，场面极其混乱。
Atul took the man's heart in his hand and began compressing it to keep blood flowing to his brain. I mean, he lost basically 10 times his body volume in blood, but we were able to give him enough blood to keep his circulation going. He had a cardiac arrest twice. We were finally able to repair the hole in the Vena Cave and get the tumor out and have him recover. A happy ending and a first blush,
阿图尔用手托住这个男人的心脏，开始挤压它，以保持血液流向他的大脑。我的意思是，他流失的血量基本上达到了他体重的10倍，但我们得以输给他足够的血液来维持他的血液循环。他心脏骤停了两次。我们终于修补好了下腔静脉上的洞，切除了肿瘤，并让他恢复了健康。初听之下，这是一个大团圆结局，
a textbook case of medical heroics. A doctor makes a mistake, but he fixes it, taking a heart into his bare hands and squeezing life back into his patient's body. This is the stuff of countless movies and TV shows. Our whole idea of the hero is the person who can kind of know it all, save the day on their own just by force of their brain and their skill. But skill and brain power were not the reason Mr. Hagueman survived.
一个堪称教科书级别的医疗英雄主义案例。医生犯了一个错误，但他弥补了过失，赤手空拳托起一颗心脏，将生命重新挤回病人的体内。这是无数电影和电视剧的常见桥段。我们对英雄的全部概念，就是那种似乎无所不知，仅凭一己之力以及自身的头脑和技能就能挽救危局的人。但技能和头脑并不是哈古曼先生能够幸存的原因。
Atul says what actually saved his patient's life was a plan the surgical team had made before they began the surgery. The plan wasn't grand or complicated. In fact, it was a humble checklist. And what happened was, when we ran the checklist, when we got to the part where we said, what's the goal of the operation and tell me anything unexpected about this. And I mentioned to the anesthesiologist that this tumor was pretty tightly against the Vena Kava. The anesthesiologist then made a plan to get more blood into the room just in case. Just in case. When disaster came he was prepared and that was the only reason that this man got through it.
阿图尔说，真正救了他病人一命的，是外科团队在手术开始前制定的一项计划。这个计划并不宏大，也不复杂。事实上，它只是一份简陋的检查清单。事情的经过是这样的：当我们过一遍检查清单时，当我们进行到讨论手术目标以及询问本次手术是否有任何意料之外的情况这一部分时，我向麻醉师提到，这个肿瘤非常紧贴着下腔静脉。于是麻醉师制定了一个计划，在手术室里多准备一些血，以防万一。以防万一。当灾难降临时，他做好了准备，而这正是这个人能够挺过难关的唯一原因。
Today on Hidden Brain the subtle biases that cause very smart and very skilled people to become their own worst enemies and how innovators have found a way to help pilots, doctors, frankly any of us perform at our best. It's a story of an ancient insight applied to modern life, and even though you might not know it, this innovation shapes life and death decisions that affect all of us. We began in the depths of the Great Depression. It was a time of great suffering and people were looking for inspiration.
今天在 Hidden Brain 节目中：导致非常聪明和极其能干的人成为自己最大敌人的微妙偏见，以及创新者如何找到方法帮助飞行员、医生——坦率地说，帮助我们所有人——发挥出最佳水平。这是一个将古老见解应用于现代生活的故事，尽管你可能并不知情，但这种创新正在塑造着影响我们所有人生死抉择。我们要从大萧条的深渊说起。那是一个苦难深重的时代，人们在寻找精神鼓舞。
Many found it in the heroes who were inventing the modern age of flight. One effort in particular caught the public's attention. Boeing was developing an airplane that was said to be different from anything that came before it. In the press, the Model 299 was known as the Flying Fortress. It's 15 tons and is reported to have cost nearly half a million. Something like the Boeing 299 was a huge story. Roger Conner is a curator at the Smithsonian National Air and Space Museum in Washington,
许多人在那些开创现代航空时代英雄身上找到了这种鼓舞。其中一项努力格外引人注目。波音公司正在开发一款据称前所未有的飞机。在媒体上，这款 299 型飞机被称为“空中堡垒”。它重达 15 吨，据报道造价接近 50 万美元。像波音 299 这样的飞机是个超级大新闻。罗杰·康纳是华盛顿特区史密森尼国家航空航天博物馆的馆长，
DC. We're standing in a part of the museum dedicated to the golden age of flight, gazing up at a model of Boeing's flying fortress. And is that the silver plane that we're looking at up high? Right, so a very streamlined four-engine aircraft, and this was really a marvel of its day. In other words, the Model 299 was a big deal, both for Boeing and for the United States.
DC。我们正站在博物馆里专门展示航空黄金时代的一个区域，抬头凝视着波音“空中堡垒”的模型。我们高处看到的那个银色飞机就是它吗？没错，这是一架非常流线型的四发飞机，这在当时确实是一个奇迹。换句话说，对于波音公司和美国而言，299 型飞机都是一件大事。
It was a, you know, a success story in America that was really challenged by depression. It was also a very big deal for the U.S. military. By all accounts, it's a wonder of technology, so the the Air Corps pilots that see it are in awe, it's a fantastic machine. The plane arrived on the scene at a time when the nation was obsessed with the possibilities of flight. Air racing was not just a niche activity for wealthy hobbyists, it was kind of a national craze and obsession. The fastest things on wings strut their amazing stuff.
你知道，这是一个饱受萧条打击的美国重现辉煌的成功故事。对美国军方来说，这也是一件大事。从各方面来看，它都是科技的奇迹，因此看到它的航空兵飞行员都惊叹不已，这是一架极好的机器。这款飞机问世时，全国正痴迷于飞行的种种可能。航空竞速不仅仅是有钱业余爱好者的一个小众活动，它简直是一种全国性的狂热和痴迷。长着翅膀的最快机器展示着它们惊人的风采。
You know, kids would obsess over who was leading the rankings at the Cleveland Air Races. The military was obsessed with the idea of long-range bombers, planes that could better protect the U.S. coastline and give the nation an edge if another great war erupted. In 1934, the Army Air Corps put out a proposal to the nation's aviation companies and challenged them to build a new, long-range bomber for the military. The prototypes were to go up against each other at a flight competition the following year. The two leading competitors are Douglas and Boeing.
你知道的，孩子们会痴迷于谁在克利夫兰飞行大赛的排名中领先。军方则痴迷于远程轰炸机这一概念——这种飞机能够更好地保护美国海岸线，并在爆发另一场大战时赋予国家优势。1934年，陆军航空兵向全国的航空企业发出招标，向它们发起挑战，要求为军方建造一款新的远程轰炸机。原型机将在次年的飞行比赛中一决高下。主要的两个竞争对手是道格拉斯和波音。
Douglas was really starting to dominate the American aircraft industry at this moment. Their DC-2 was becoming the hot passenger airliner and was quickly putting Boeing into the background in that industry. So once the Air Corps announces this new bomber competition, Boeing is really eager to show off and demonstrate that they can lead the pack. Boeing had a lot to prove. By the time the competition rolled around, it had an ace up its sleeve, the flying fortress. On October 30th, 1935, the day of the competition, Boeing's streamlined silver behemoth was the clear frontrunner.
在这个时期，道格拉斯确实开始在美国飞机制造行业占据主导地位。他们的 DC-2 正在成为热门的客运客机，并迅速让波音在该行业中退居幕后。因此，一旦航空兵部队宣布这项新的轰炸机竞赛，波音就急于炫耀并证明他们能够引领群雄。波音有太多的证明要去做。当比赛到来时，它手中握有一张王牌——“空中堡垒”。1935年10月30日，比赛当天，波音那架流线型的银色庞然大物成了明显的领跑者。
The morning of the competition, flight teams from Boeing, Douglas and Martin, assembled with military leaders at Wright Field in Dayton, Ohio. Early in the morning, with 9 o'clock in the morning, and apparently by all accounts, a very beautiful day, so kind of ideal conditions for a late October day in Ohio, and perfect day for a test flight, really. A crowd watched as the Boeing 299 taxi to the runway. Advances, the power, engine spool up, is rolling down the runway.
比赛当天的早晨，来自波音、道格拉斯和马丁公司的飞行团队与军方领导人一起聚集在俄亥俄州代顿的莱特机场。大清早，早上九点钟，从各方面来看显然是个非常晴朗的日子——对于俄亥俄州十月下旬的一天来说，条件可以说是理想之选，而且确实是进行试飞的完美一天。人群注视着波音 299 滑向跑道。推进，动力，引擎转速提升，它正在跑道上滑行。
The beautiful airplane lifted into the air. It had all the makings of a winner. And then the observers noted that the aircraft starts to abruptly pitch up. So as it takes off, rather than gradually rising and building up speed, the nose just rising and building up speed, the nose just starts to pick up and up and immediately observers on the ground realize something is wrong.
这架美丽的飞机升空了。它具备了一架获胜飞机的所有要素。随后，观察员们注意到这架飞机开始突兀地仰头向上。因此，在它起飞时，并没有逐渐爬升并积蓄速度，而是机头径直开始向上抬起并加速，机头刚开始向上抬起，地面上的观察员立刻意识到情况不对劲。
Very wrong. At 300 feet, the aircraft stalled. As people watched in horror, the flying fortress began to plummet toward the Earth. It impacts the ground in a flat attitude and in person to flames. There were five crewmen on board. Major ployer Hill, who was the chief of flight tests for right field, Leslie Tower, who was the chief of flight test pilot. There was also Donald Tut, who was acting as the co-pilot.
大错特错。在 300 英尺的高空，飞机失速了。在人们惊恐的注视下，“空中堡垒”开始向地面坠落。它以平直的姿态撞击地面，瞬间陷入火海。机上当时有五名机组人员。担任莱特机场首席试飞员的少校普洛耶·希尔，以及担任首席试飞员的莱斯利·托尔。还有担任副驾驶的唐纳德·塔特。
There was a mechanic on board, Mark Cougler, and John Cutting, who was one of the aeronautical engineers involved with the program. Obsovers on the ground raised to what the wreck. Obviously an aircraft like this has a lot of fuel on board, and so when in this case, because the aircraft came down relatively flat, it only just started to spin in, it would have been fairly apparent to the people on the ground. There was a good chance of survivors. So it's kind of a worst case scenario where you see that the aircraft is involved in terms
机上还有一名机械师马克·库格勒，以及参与该项目的航空工程师之一约翰·卡廷。地面的观察员冲向残骸。很显然，像这样的一架飞机携带有大量燃油，因此在这种情况下，由于飞机是以相对平直的姿态坠落的，只是刚刚开始旋转着坠毁，对于地面上的人来说，这应该是相当明显的。有很大的生还可能。所以这算是一种最糟糕的情况，你看到飞机失事起火，但你知道上面的人可能还活着。因此，这对救援人员和机上人员来说都将是极大的危险。
of being on fire, but you know there's people on there that are likely still alive. So it's going to be a great hazard to both the rescuers as well as the occupants of the aircraft. Three of those occupants survived, but two died, blow your hill and Leslie Tower. Both were highly experienced pilots. Almost immediately people asked, what made the flying fortress crash? This aircraft did have an autopilot and not unlike a lot of accidents today, attention centered on that. So was the autopilot somehow engaged where it was overriding the inputs of the crew members. So that was one focus of the investigation, but very quickly attention turned to a control locking mechanism, which was, that was one of the advanced features of this aircraft,
机上有三人生还，但有两人遇难：普洛耶·希尔和莱斯利·托尔。两人都是经验极其丰富的飞行员。人们几乎立刻问道：是什么导致了“空中堡垒”坠毁？这架飞机确实配备了自动驾驶仪，和今天的许多事故并无二致，人们的注意力集中在了这一点上。那么，是否是自动驾驶仪在某种程度上处于开启状态，从而覆盖了机组成员的手动操作？因此这是调查的重点之一，但很快人们的注意力就转向了一个操纵锁定机构，这是该飞机的先进功能之一，
was that it had its own built-in mechanism for locking the elevator for when it was essentially parked on the ground. The elevator determines the pitch of the plane, basically the movement of the nose up or down. For most planes at the time, elevator locks were on the outside, meaning ground crew had to unlock them before take-off. But in the Model 299, the elevator lock was inside the cabin of the plane. The crew had forgotten to unlock it. And so after the plane took off, the pilots found they couldn't level off.
即它拥有内置机构，用于在飞机基本上停在地面上时锁住升降舵。升降舵决定了飞机的俯仰角，也就是机头向上或向下的运动。对于当时的大多数飞机来说，升降舵锁都在外部，这意味着地面人员必须在起飞前将其解锁。但在 299 型飞机上，升降舵锁在飞机座舱内部。机组人员忘记将其解锁了。因此飞机起飞后，飞行员发现他们无法保持水平飞行。
The nose just kept climbing. Unfortunately, in the, you know, just the matter of a few seconds that they're airborne, it's just not enough time to deal with it. So less than 20 seconds between the time the wheels leave the ground and the aircraft is entering the stalls, it's just not enough time for that awareness to dawn, be able to reach the controls, particularly as the aircraft is beginning to stall
机头一直在往上爬。不幸的是，在他们身处空中的这区区几秒钟时间内，根本没有足够的时间来处理它。因此，从车轮离开地面到飞机进入失速状态，前后不到20秒，根本没有足够的时间让这种意识觉醒，并够到控制装置，尤其是当飞机开始失速时，
then the ability of somebody to find the controls and solve the problem. It's too late and they may not be able to physically do it because they're getting thrown around the aircraft. The death of the two men was a crushing blow. For military leaders and the aviation industry, the crash prompted an unsettling question. If experienced pilots like Ployer Hill and Leslie Tower could make fatal mistakes with the flying fortress, what did that mean for the future of manned air flight? What planes simply becoming too complicated to fly? At this moment in mid-1930s, the performance of aircraft are changing so rapidly, there's so many new complex systems coming into play, rather delicate systems in some ways. So everything from retractable landing gear to turbochargers for engines, all of which require their own
随后某人寻找控制装置并解决问题的能力。为时已晚，而且他们可能无法在物理上做到这一点，因为他们在飞机里被撞得东倒西歪。这两名男子的死是一个沉重的打击。对军方领导人和航空业而言，这次坠机引发了一个令人不安的问题：如果像普洛耶·希尔和莱斯利·托尔这样经验丰富的飞行员都会驾驶“空中堡垒”犯下致命错误，那对载人航空的未来意味着什么？难道飞机变得过于复杂而无法飞行了吗？在20世纪30年代中期这一时期，飞机的性能变化如此之快，有那么多新的复杂系统投入使用，在某些方面甚至是相当脆弱的系统。因此，从可收放起落架到发动机的涡轮增压器，所有这些都需要各自详尽的操作规范。
detailed specifications for operation. And so now a pilot was beginning to become overwhelmed with the degree of complexity with all these systems and how they interfaced with one another. It became difficult to keep them straight. To many of us, the instinctive solution to this problem might be more training. Spend more time in the plane. Get to know it, like you know your own home. Understand its quirks inside and out.
因此，现在飞行员开始被所有这些系统及其相互交织的复杂程度压得喘不过气来。要把它们理清楚变得很困难。对我们许多人来说，针对这个问题的本能解决方案可能是更多的训练。在飞机上花更多时间。了解它，就像了解你自己的家一样。里里外外摸清它的脾气。
But Roger says that kind of thinking may not have saved the man who died in the crash. The pilots actually had lots of experience with the plane. They had been flying it for several months. Things had become rather routine in testing this aircraft. So certainly the crew, both at right field and with Boeing, were fairly familiar with it. They had clearly become quite comfortable with the operation of the aircraft and were used to its quirks and how it performed. So if more training was in the answer, what was?
但罗杰说，那种想法可能无法拯救在坠机中丧生的那个人。飞行员们实际上对这架飞机有着丰富的经验。他们已经驾驶它好几个月了。在测试这架飞机的过程中，事情已经变得相当常规化。因此，无论是莱特机场还是波音公司的机组人员，对它都相当熟悉。他们显然对飞机的操作变得非常适应，并习惯了它的脾气和性能。所以，如果更多的训练不是答案，那答案是什么？
The solution that military leaders devised was fundamentally about human psychology. Pilots were not screwing up because they were incompetent. They were screwing up because they were very good. So good that they were completely sure they knew what they were doing. They didn't feel the need to slow down, go over the basics, like unlocking the elevator before taking off. The military responded with a new idea that was actually an old idea, the checklist.
军方领导人设计出的解决方案从根本上讲关乎人类心理学。飞行员搞砸了并不是因为他们无能。他们搞砸是因为他们太优秀了。优秀到他们完全确信自己知道自己在做什么。他们觉得没有必要慢下来，去重温基础知识，比如起飞前解锁升降舵。军方用一个新想法作出了回应，而这个新想法其实是个老主意——检查清单。
In the cockpit, you learn to follow the checklist because it helps you to keep your mind on your work. Details important when you're flying a big bomber. And using the checklist means you don't overlook a thing. This is from a 1943 military training film. After you get the plane off the ramp and down near the runway, you're ready for the run-up. One of the most important checks of all. Setter at an angle.
在驾驶舱里，你学会遵循检查清单，因为它能帮助你把心思放在工作上。当你驾驶一架大型轰炸机时，细节至关重要。使用检查清单意味着你不会忽略任何事情。这段视频出自 1943 年的一部军事训练片。当你把飞机驶离停机坪靠近跑道后，你就准备好进行试车了。这是所有检查中最重要的一项之一。将飞机停成一个角度，
That gets all your props safe over concrete for the run-up and if there's a guy behind you, you won't blast him when you rev him up. What's fascinating is you look at the effort that went into training these guys. The training videos that came out of that time are really magnificent. There, frankly, you'd be hard pressed to find something as well produced today for the same purpose. Checklists like these were widely implemented in the military in the years after the Boeing 299 crash.
这能确保你的所有螺旋桨都在混凝土上方安全地进行试车，而且如果你后面有人，当你轰油门时就不会把气流吹到他身上。令人着迷的是，你看一下在训练这些家伙时所付出的努力。那个时代出品的训练视频真的是相当精彩。坦率地说，你很难找到今天能有制作得如此精良、达到同样目的的东西。像这样的检查清单在波音 299 坠毁后的几年里在军方得到了广泛推行。
They cover tasks that, to a train pilot, might seem mind-numbingly obvious. Make sure your crew is in the right position and that the hatches are closed. Turn off the automatic pilot. Make sure your flight controls and tail wheel are unlocked. Check that your brakes have air pressure, that your warning lights work. Supercharger that's set correctly to low-blower, your altimeter set to the correct field elevation. Mixture controls, you have to be in your full-rich position, carburetor air, you want
它们涵盖了对受过训练的飞行员来说可能枯燥乏味到显而易见任务。确保你的机组人员处于正确的位置并且舱门已关闭。关闭自动驾驶仪。确保你的飞行操纵面和尾轮已解锁。检查你的刹车有气压，警报灯工作正常。增压器正确设置为低增压档，高度计设置为正确的高度。混合比控制杆，你必须处于全富油位置，化油器空气，为了获得最大性能，你希望将其置于冷空气位置。
in the cold position for maximum performance. So to be honest, as somebody who doesn't know how to fly an aircraft, a lot of this is gobbledy-gook to me. But I'm imagining that for most people who are pilots, this stuff is actually completely routine. That this is no different than me getting into my car in the morning and saying, open the door, sit down and close the door behind you. That it seems really basic stuff.
老实说，作为一个不会开飞机的人，这里面有很多对我来说都是莫名其妙的行话。但我猜想，对于大多数飞行员来说，这些东西其实完全是常规操作。这和我每天早上上车时说：打开车门，坐进去，关上车门，并没有什么不同。这看起来真的很基础。
And I would imagine that someone would have told me to do that when I got into my car each morning. I would say, what kind of bureaucratic nonsense is this? I know how to fly a plane. I'm an experienced pilot. Stop telling me how to do my job. Certainly. So this has been a huge problem in aviation culture and it's one that does crop up. In other words, checklists can help experts slow down, but only if the experts bother to listen. It turns out lots of pilots didn't want to listen. How to make them? Harness another large bias in the brain, our willingness to be swept up by stories. There are so many accounts now of episodes where people have winged the checklists or not paid attention
我想如果有人每天早上我上车时都这么吩咐我，我会说：这是什么官僚主义的废话？我知道怎么开飞机。我是个经验丰富的飞行员。别告诉我要怎么做我的工作。确实如此。因此，这一直是航空文化中的一个大问题，而且确实时有发生。换句话说，检查清单可以帮助专家慢下来，但前提是专家们愿意听取。事实证明，很多飞行员并不想听。如何让他们听从？利用大脑中的另一个重大偏见——我们乐于被故事吸引的心理倾向。现在有太多的记录显示，人们曾草率应付检查清单或不够专注，从而导致了糟糕的事情发生。
and something bad's happened. So, particularly in commercial aviation and over the last half century, there's been a very strong cultural emphasis on really the storytelling that you go and look at these accidents. So, Air Florida 1982 here in Washington, D in Washington DC is a very famous one. 3.4-0 now on and down off 14 to 3.3. Now my 417. There's the crash over the Everglades.
因此，特别是在商业航空领域以及过去半个世纪以来，一直有一种非常强烈的文化强调，即真正通过讲故事的方式让你去审视这些事故。因此，1982年华盛顿特区的佛罗里达航空航班就是个非常著名的例子。3.4-0 现在开始下降离开 14 到 3.3。现在我的 417。那里发生了大沼泽地空难。
I'm a Dirtry Eastern 417 just turned on fire. Eastern 417, continue approach to 9 left. Where they were focused on the nose gear. There's a whole series of very well-known accidents that are brought up in training at various points that are discussing simulator exercises and are on the present really in the literature. So there are inevitably a number of points
我是达美东方航空 417，刚刚着火。东方航空 417，继续进近 9 左跑道。他们当时把注意力集中在前起落架上。在各个阶段的培训中都会提及一系列广为人知的事故，这些事故会在模拟机训练中进行讨论，并且真正无处不在地存在于相关文献中。因此，商业航空公司飞行员必然会有多次机会目睹这些驾驶舱重现，并看到各种事件的语音记录，在这些事件中，机组人员有点像是在即兴盲飞。他们全凭直觉飞行，没有遵循程序，没有以正确的方式使用检查清单，从而导致了糟糕结果的发生。
where a commercial airline pilot will have witnessed these cockpit recreations and seen the voice transcripts of various episodes where crews have kind of winged it. They've flown by the seat of the pants, they've not followed procedures, not used the checklist in the right way, and something bad has come about of it. The commercial aviation industry developed a culture of making and using checklists through training, simulations, and storytelling. The military went a step further and Harnes broader themes patriotism, freedom.
商业航空业通过培训、模拟和讲故事，发展出了一种制定和使用检查清单的文化。军方则更进一步，利用了更广泛的主题——爱国主义、自由。
America goes to war. Men of the army, Navy and Marines reinforce the battlefronts on six continents to save the homes and ideals of free men from Axis domination. Despite the crash in Dayton, the army ended up ordering thousands of Boeing's Model 299, which it renamed the B-17. Once the nation entered World War II, thousands of young would-be pilots put up their hands to fly those planes. Each of the young cadets is to get real flying instruction under the army's new plan of giving every undergraduate at West Point a certain amount of air experience.
美国参战了。陆军、海军和海军陆战队的将士们增援了六个大洲的战线，以拯救自由人的家园和理想免受轴心国统治。尽管在代顿发生了坠机事故，陆军最终还是订购了数千架波音 299 型飞机，并将其重新命名为 B-17。一旦国家卷入二战，成千上万年轻的准飞行员便举手报名驾驶这些飞机。根据陆军的新计划，每位年轻学员都将接受真正的飞行指导，该计划旨在让西点军校的每一位本科生都获得一定程度的空中飞行经验。
They're all for it too and what a fine looking group of young men they are. The cream of the country, modern warfare will be fought as much in the air as on the ground. And the new war department policy looks to the time when every army officer will be trained to fly as an observer if not as a pilot. Many of these new pilots were not officers, though. Many were young and listed men. Most of whom were, you know, 19, 20-year-olds, literally fresh off the farm, you know,
他们对此也非常赞同，看这群朝气蓬勃的年轻小伙子多么精神。他们是国家的精锐，现代战争将在空中和地面进行同样激烈的战斗。而新的战争部政策则着眼于这样一个时代：每个陆军军官都将接受培训，即使不能作为飞行员，也要作为观察员飞行。然而，许多这些新飞行员并不是军官。许多人是年轻的入伍士兵。他们大多数人，你知道的，都是19、20岁的年轻人，简直刚从农场走出来，你知道的，
with not a great deal of training. And so they're going to be operating very complex systems. And a lot of cases, the aircraft are even getting more complicated than they're going to 9.9. For these new pilots, checklists served as a safety net. They helped them get these massive planes off the ground. They were used by flight teams to troubleshoot problems in the air. And perhaps most importantly, they helped exhausted pilots avoid mistakes while returning home
并没有接受过太多的培训。因此，他们将操作非常复杂的系统。在许多情况下，这些飞机甚至比 299 型变得更加复杂。对于这些新飞行员来说，检查清单就像是一张安全网。它们帮助这些庞大的飞机离开地面。它们被飞行团队用来排除空中的故障。而且也许最重要的是，它们帮助筋疲力尽的飞行员在执行任务返航时避免犯错。
from a mission. We can't know for sure how the use of checklists affected America's success in the war, but Roger is sure that they saved lives. If those checklists had not been integrated to that level at the start of World War II, it's reasonable to assume that many hundreds and probably thousands of lives would have been lost due to that. Today, checklists are essential to the aviation world. In fact, there are big reasons commercial aviation is significantly safer than driving
我们无法确切知道检查清单的使用对美国在战争中的成功有多大影响，但罗杰确信它们挽救了生命。如果在二战开始时这些检查清单没有被整合到这种程度，可以合理推测，由于缺乏检查清单，将会损失数以百计甚至数以千计的生命。如今，检查清单对航空世界至关重要。事实上，这就是商业航空显著比在高速公路上开车更安全的重要原因。
your car on a highway. Checklists have become ubiquitous and lots of other fields too, fields where the work is complex and the cost of mistakes is high. Construction crews now rely on checklists to build high-rise office towers. NASA has detailed to-do lists for astronauts. And then there's a world of medicine. I don't get through a week of surgery
检查清单在许多其他领域也变得无处不在，在这些领域中，工作很复杂，犯错的代价很高。建筑工人现在依靠检查清单来建造高层办公楼。NASA 为宇航员准备了详细的待办事项清单。然后是医学界。我做一周的手术，
without us catching something that would have meant the patient didn't get as good care as they would have otherwise. Coming up, how the powerful culture of aviation checklist has inspired and antagonized the field of medicine, and how one grieving mother's question helped to change an entire culture. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. Atul Kawande is a surgeon at Brigham & Women's Hospital in Boston and the author of the Checklist Manifesto.
总能揪出一些问题，否则病人的治疗效果就会大打折扣。接下来：航空检查清单强大的文化是如何启发并对立于医学领域的，以及一位悲痛母亲的质问如何帮助改变了整个文化。请继续收听。这里是 Hidden Brain，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。阿图尔·加万德是波士顿布莱根妇女医院的外科医生，也是《检查清单宣言》的作者。
When he began his career in medicine, checklists weren't something Atul spent a lot of time thinking about. He was drawn to the heroics of doctors, people who, through the force of their intellect and the rigor of that training, could triumph over death and restore patients to productive lives. I went into medicine because I wanted to be able to understand how does the body work, how does it go wrong, and then how can I come in and save the day.
当他开始从医生涯时，检查清单并不是阿图尔花很多时间去思考的事情。他被医生的英雄主义所吸引，这些人凭借其智慧的力量和严格的训练，能够战胜死神，让患者重获健康的生活。我选择从医学是因为我想了解身体是如何运作的，它是如何出问题的，然后我该如何介入并拯救危局。
And what I was really drawn to was in surgery where, you know, it's especially visceral. It's like, how do I save this person with my own hands? Over the years, though, Atul started to realize that daring and intellect weren't enough, particularly as medicine has become more complicated and doctors have evolved into what he calls super, super specialists. I am one of those super, super specialists now. I am a general surgeon in my original training,
而真正吸引我的是外科手术，你知道的，这特别直观。就像是：我如何用自己的双手拯救这个人？然而多年来，阿图尔开始意识到，胆识和智谋是远远不够的，特别是随着医学变得越来越复杂，医生们已经演变成他所说的超级超级专科医生。我现在就是那些超级超级专科医生之一。我最初接受的是普外科培训，
but then I've narrowed into not only a cancer surgery, but a focus on three specific tumors that make me feel like I have an area where I can know more than just about anybody at least here regionally, right? So the problem is that even then, I'm not necessarily able to pull together in that moment in time, everything that might matter. Even a super, super specialist can screw up. Having advanced training doesn't guarantee perfection. It's still possible that you'll forget something important.
但随后我的专业范围进一步缩小，不仅专注于癌症外科，还聚焦于三种特定的肿瘤，这让我觉得我拥有了一个至少在这里的区域内，我所知可以超越几乎任何人的领域，对吧？所以问题在于，即便如此，我也未必能在那个特定的时刻将所有可能重要的事情全部统筹起来。即使是超级超级专科医生也会搞砸。拥有高级培训并不能保证万无一失。你仍然可能会忘记重要的事情。
Overlook a problem until it's too late. Or nick a blood vessel, even though you've done the same kind of surgery dozens of times. At old search for a solution led into the aviation world and its culture of checklist. We are famously hold up the airline industry as an example of high reliability performance. You can have planes that are of now immense complexity, immense power, and we have a far lower crash rate than when they were far simpler.
忽视了一个问题，直到为时已晚。或者刮破一条血管，尽管你已经做过几十次同类手术。阿图尔寻找解决方案的努力将他引向了航空界及其检查清单文化。我们总是把航空业奉为高可靠性性能的典范。你可以拥有极其复杂、动力极为庞大的飞机，而我们的坠机率却远低于它们远为简单的时候。
And less than one in 200,000 flights have any kind of a mishap and so on. He studied that 1935 crash of the flying fortress. He couldn't help but compare the military's response to the way his own field response to fatal errors. If we were looking at solving this problem the way we would solve it in medicine, we would say, well, let's have a four-year training fellowship and how to fly the B-17 bomber. And instead, what they did was they created a checklist for the most common ways that even an expert pilot could crash that plane.
而且每 20 万次飞行中发生各类事故的比例还不到一次，诸如此类。他研究了 1935 年“空中堡垒”的那次坠机事故。他情不自禁地将军方的反应与他自己领域对致命错误的反应进行对比。如果我们打算像在医学中解决问题那样来解决这个问题，我们会说，好吧，让我们搞一个为期四年的培训进修项目，教大家怎么开 B-17 轰炸机。而相反，他们所做的是，为甚至连专家级飞行员都可能导致该飞机坠毁的最常见方式创建了一份检查清单。
And that one-page checklist allowed them to fly that plane two million miles without a single mishap. No four-year specialized training program, get it all into your brain and make it work that way. It was just a whole different way of looking at things, and that's what was powerful to me. Checklists were not, of course, completely absent from the world of medicine. Nurses have long used them in many areas of patient care, but adults says for many doctors
那份一页纸的检查清单让他们驾驶这架飞机飞行了二百万英里而没有发生一起事故。没有为期四年的专业培训项目，不用把所有东西都塞进脑子里然后那样去运作。这完全是另一种看待事物的方式，这对我来说很有冲击力。当然，医学界并非完全没有检查清单。护士在许多患者护理领域长期使用检查清单，但阿图尔说，对许多医生而言，
the idea of relying on a checklist was demeaning. Our values as physicians or experts of any kind are that we believe in autonomy. Leave me alone, I've been trained, I know the best thing to do, and that is your best bet for getting the best results out of whatever you're turning to me for. bed for getting the best results out of whatever you're turning to me for. 700 miles away at Johns Hopkins Medicine in Baltimore, physician Peter Pronevost was struggling with the same problem. Peter had a perspective on patient safety that many doctors don't. He was in his fourth year of medical school when his father was misdiagnosed with a wrong cancer. Lymphoma instead of
依赖检查清单的想法是有失身份的。我们作为医生或任何领域的专家的价值观是，我们崇尚自主权。别管我，我受过训练，我知道该怎么做最好，而这正是你从我这里获得最佳治疗结果的最大保障。在 700 英里之外的巴尔的摩约翰斯·霍普金斯医学院，医生彼得·普罗诺沃斯特也在与同样的问题做斗争。彼得对患者安全有着许多医生所没有的视角。当他的父亲被误诊为另一种癌症时，他正读医学院四年级。得了淋巴瘤，而不是
leukemia. And by the time they got it right, he came home with hospice and not only did he die, but he suffered miserably in pain for a week being told, oh, he has enough pain medicines. And at that time, I became convinced that health care often lets our patients down and they deserve more. Peter was determined to do better by his patients. Figuring out exactly what that means in practice
白血病。等他们确诊时，父亲带着临终关怀回家了，不仅撒手人寰，而且在痛苦中痛苦地折磨了一个星期，期间还被告知：哦，他已经用了足够多的止痛药了。正是在那个时候，我开始坚信，医疗保健常常让我们的患者失望，他们值得拥有更好的对待。彼得决心为他的病人做得更好。弄清楚这在实践中究竟意味着什么，
became a major goal of his work at Johns Hopkins. The work really accelerated back in 2001 after an adorable little girl, Josie King, died of a catheter infection. And those infections to give you a perspective Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel
成了他在约翰斯·霍普金斯大学工作的一个主要目标。这项工作在 2001 年真正加速了，当时一个可爱的小女孩乔西·金因导管感染而死。为了让你有个直观的概念，那些感染...
and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Joel and Her mom's surreal came to me and said, could you tell me that my daughter is less likely to die now than a year ago? And I looked at her and reflected and said, I can't. A catheter is a thin tube that's inserted into the bladder to remove urine. Other times, catheters are put into the veins around the neck when a patient needs medicine or a blood transfusion. Hospitals around the world use catheters all the time, and those same hospitals routinely have problems when bacteria get into the tubing.
她的母亲苏瑞尔来到我身边对我说：“你能告诉我，现在我的女儿比一年前更有可能活下来吗？”我看着她，反思了一下，回答说：“我不能。”导管是一根插入膀胱以排出尿液的细管。有时，当患者需要药物或输血时，导管会被插入脖子周围的静脉中。世界各地的医院一直在使用导管，而这些同样的医院在细菌进入管道时也经常会遇到问题。
Sometimes the infections caused by those bacteria can be so serious they lead to death, as in the case of Josie King. At the time we just accepted those infections as the norm. That is the story that we told about health care was that sometimes when you treat old or young or very sick patients, little girls like Josie are going to die. There was a straightforward solution. The Centers for Disease Control and Prevention had rolled out a checklist to prevent catheter-born infections.
有时由这些细菌引起的感染非常严重，以至于会导致死亡，就像乔西·金的情况一样。当时我们只是将这些感染视为常态。我们对医疗保健的说法是：有时当你治疗老年人、幼儿或重症患者时，像乔西这样的小女孩就会死去。有一个直接的解决方案。疾病控制与预防中心推出了一份用于预防导管感染的检查清单。
It included things like wash your hands with soap before inserting the catheter, cover the patients with sterile drapes, make sure that doctors and nurses wear gloves, hats, masks, and gowns. The checklist seems so obvious, so easy to follow, but Peter quickly found that creating a checklist is only the first step. There are lots of reasons for doctors and nurses to ignore it. To get all the equipment needed with the checklist, a cap, a gown, and masks, doctors had to go to eight different places, a capsule and one-placed masks or another, and when
它包括诸如：插入导管前用肥皂洗手，用无菌单覆盖患者，确保医生和护士佩戴手套、帽子、口罩和手术衣。这份检查清单看起来如此显而易见，如此容易遵循，但彼得很快发现，创建检查清单只是第一步。医生和护士忽视它的原因有很多。为了凑齐检查清单所需的所有设备——帽子、手术衣和口罩，医生们不得不去八个不同的地方，帽子在一个地方，口罩在另一个地方，而当
the equipment wasn't stocked and it often wasn't, The doctors made in their mind what was a rational economic decision. They said, if I go spend 10 minutes to run down the hall or to another unit to get this piece of equipment, that's 10 minutes I'm going to spend not caring for another patient or doing something else because there was no slack time. And if I go without it, the infection is invisible. It's in the future. And it may not really be prevented anyways. So they often decided to go without it. So what we did was said, okay, let's make a cart. Let's get all the equipment we need, store in one place, make sure someone's assigned to stock it, and now compliance with the checklist went from 30 to 75%.
设备没有备齐时——这种情况经常发生，医生们在心智上做出了一个理性的经济决定。他们会说，如果我花 10 分钟跑下走廊或去另一个科室拿这个设备，那将是我无法用来照顾另一个病人或做其他事情的 10 分钟，因为根本没有空闲时间。如果我不拿它，感染是看不见的。它发生在未来。而且无论如何它可能也无法真正被预防。所以他们经常决定不用它。于是我们所做的就是说，好吧，让我们弄辆推车。把我们需要的所有设备都集中存放在一个地方，确保有人负责备货，现在检查清单的执行率从 30% 上升到了 75%。
But even when all the supplies were closed at hand, there was a deeper problem that had to do with the culture of medicine, the power dynamic between doctors and nurses. Peter told nurses that they had the authority to stop physicians when they tried to put in catheters without following the checklist. It caused an uproar. The doctor said, you can't have a nurse question me in public. It makes me look like I don't know something, to which I said, welcome to the human race.
但即使所有的物资都触手可及，还有一个更深层次的问题，那就是医学文化、医生和护士之间的权力动力学。彼得告诉护士，当医生试图在不遵循检查清单的情况下插入导管时，她们有权阻止医生。这引发了一场轩然大波。医生说：“你不能让一个护士在公开场合质问我。这让我显得自己什么都不懂。”对此我的回答是：“欢迎来到人类社会。
We all don't know things. And the nurses said, I'm not gonna question a doctor because if I do, I'll get my head bit off. I'm tired of being yelled at. It's too risky. And so I pulled the team together and said, do you all agree that harm should be prevented in this hospital?
我们大家都有不懂的事情。”护士们则说：“我才不会去质问医生，因为如果我这么做了，我会被骂得狗血淋头。我受够了被大喊大叫。这太冒险了。”于是我把团队召集到一起，问道：“大家是否同意在这个医院里应该防止伤害发生？”
Yes, of course, Peter. We should never harm patients. And do you agree that the items on the checklist are scientifically sound that patients should get them all the time? Yes, we agree with this, Peter. I said, then, okay, let me be clear. Doctors, you have permission to forget to use an item on the checklist. We're human. We're going to. But you don't have permission to need to use an item on the checklist. We're human, we're going to,
“是的，当然，彼得。我们绝不应该伤害患者。”“那你们是否同意检查清单上的项目在科学上是健全的，患者应该在任何时候都得到这些落实？”“是的，我们同意这一点，彼得。”我说：“那好吧，让我把话说清楚。医生们，你们有权忘记使用检查清单上的某项内容。我们是人，我们会犯忘事。但你们没有权利不必要地将患者置于危险之中。所以如果你忘了，护士、患者或其他任何人都会质问你，而你得回去纠正它。不是因为权力，而是因为这对患者来说是正确的事。护士们，如果你们被骂得狗血淋头，请随时在白天或晚上传呼我。”
but you don't have permission to needlessly put patients at risk. So if you forget, nurse or patient or anybody else will question you and you will go back to fix it. Not because of power, but because it's the right thing to do for patients. And nurses, please page me any time of day or night if you get your head bit off. Peter wasn't paged, and the number of patients developing infections started to drop. Compliance went from 75% with the checklist to around 98%. Infection rates went from five per thousand
彼得没有被传呼，出现感染的患者人数开始下降。检查清单的执行率从 75% 左右上升到了 98% 左右。感染率从每千个
catheter days to two, and so we knew we were on to something, and so we started investigating every infection as a defect to get changing the narrative that no longer are these inevitable, but they're preventable. And what did we find? Well, we found now that the remaining infections were often in people who had catheters for a long time.
导管日 5 例下降到 2 例，于是我们知道我们找到了对策，因此我们开始把每一次感染都当作一个缺陷来调查，以改变这种叙事：这些不再是不可避免的，而是可以预防的。我们发现了什么？好吧，我们现在发现，剩下的感染通常发生在留置导管时间较长的患者身上。
And it had nothing to do with how we inserted them, the checklist I had originally made, but how we maintained them, how the nurses accessed them. So we made a checklist for that and made sure that they accessed the catheters the right way and infection rates went to zero. Indeed, we went over a year without having any of these infections. And it was just a remarkable new narrative that with a disciplined focus and cohesive effort, harm could be eliminated.
这与我们如何插入导管（我最初制作的检查清单）无关，而是与我们如何维护它们、护士如何接触它们有关。因此我们为此制作了一份检查清单，确保他们以正确的方式接触导管，感染率降到了零。事实上，我们有一年多的时间没有发生任何此类感染。这是一个了不起的新叙事：通过纪律严明的专注和齐心协力的努力，伤害是可以被消除的。
Peter became an evangelist for checklist, but he was often asked whether the results he got at Hopkins, one of the nation's top medical centers, could be replicated in smaller cash strapped hospitals. He got his chance to study the question in 2004 when the state of Michigan decided to try using the catheter checklist in more than 100 of its hospitals. The results, which were published in the New England Journal of Medicine, showed a dramatic drop in catheter-related infection rates in that state all the way to zero. Those results were maintained throughout the 18 months of the study and in a follow-up study with 90 of the hospitals that was published in 2010.
彼得成了检查清单的布道者，但他经常被问到，他在霍普金斯（全国顶尖医疗中心之一）取得的成果是否能在资金捉襟见肘的小型医院中复制。他在 2004 年迎来了研究这个问题的机会，当时密歇根州决定在其 100 多家医院中尝试使用导管检查清单。这些结果发表在《新英格兰医学杂志》上，显示该州的导管相关感染率急剧下降，一直降到了零。这些成果在整个 18 个月的试验期间得以维持，并在 2010 年发表的针对其中 90 家医院的后续研究中得到了印证。
Peter has since left Johns Hopkins. In the year since his research there, many hospital systems have tried out versions of his checklists. Some of those efforts have been successful. Others not so much. Why? Checklists are really only as good as the teams that implement them. Peter says, teams that work in a top-down bureaucratic fashion are simply less likely to benefit from checklists. Too often we tell people how to do things. That is the checklist without explaining why and what's it's important. I'll never forget I was working with a nurse manager putting one of our projects in and the ICU attending who were passionate about this stuff. They got religion. They picked up
彼得此后离开约翰斯·霍普金斯大学。在他那里的研究发表之后的几年里，许多医院系统都尝试了其检查清单的版本。其中一些努力取得了成功，另一些则效果一般。为什么？检查清单的好坏最终取决于执行它们的团队。彼得说，以自上而下的官僚作风工作的团队，基本上不太可能从检查清单中受益。我们太常告诉人们该如何做事——也就是只给检查清单，而不解释为什么以及为什么重要。我永远不会忘记，当时我正与一位护士长一起推进我们的一个项目，而重症监护室的主治医生对这些事情充满热情。他们顿悟了。他们拿起了
the Hopkins checklist and said Peter this is great. We will go tell our staff that they will use your checklist. There's no question. We will force them to use it and I said you won't work. Do not do that. Have a conversation with them about why this is important. Ask them if little girls like Joe's, they are dying in their hospital, and if that's acceptable. Discuss that the goal of zero infection is. And then say, let's figure out how to make sure patients always get this best practice.
霍普金斯核对表，并说：“彼得，这太棒了。我们要告诉员工，他们必须使用你的核对表。毫无疑问，我们要强迫他们使用。”我说：“这行不通。千万别那样做。跟他们聊聊为什么这很重要。问问他们，像乔伊这样的小女孩在他们的医院里死去，这是否可以接受。讨论一下零感染的目标是什么。然后说，让我们想办法确保患者始终能得到这种最佳实践。”
So engaging people to co-create the solutions and respecting their wisdom and autonomy is really important in how we do this. Engaging people in this deep way, talking with them about shared goals, working together to translate those goals into a to-do list that they could use every day, all this takes a lot of work. Skeptics have asked Peter whether his system works only in relatively straightforward settings. You really can't follow five simple rules when inserting a catheter. But what about when you're doing surgery? There is no recipe for doing an operation. There are a million ways the things can go wrong.
因此，让人们参与共同创建解决方案，并尊重他们的智慧和自主权，对于我们如何做到这一点非常重要。以这种深厚的方式让人们参与进来，与他们讨论共同的目标，共同努力将这些目标转化为他们每天都可以使用的待办事项清单，所有这些都需要大量的工作。怀疑论者曾问彼得，他的系统是否只适用于相对简单的环境。在插入导管时，你真的无法遵循五个简单的规则。但是，当你做手术时呢？做手术是没有固定处方的。事情出错的方式有一百万种。
When we come back, we're going to go into the operating room. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. Surgeon Atul Gawande has quite literally written the book on the power of checklist to help us grapple with complicated tasks. But there was a time not long ago when Artool would routinely perform a complex surgery without a checklist. Sometimes, he wouldn't even know all the people he was working alongside in the operating room. I would just walk in, it was kind of expected to be a silent place where people didn't ask a lot of questions, they're just supposed to know what they're doing, and then you just
当我们回来时，我们将进入手术室。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。外科医生阿图尔·加万德确实写了一本关于核对表力量的书，帮助我们应对复杂的任务。但不久前，阿图尔经常在没有核对表的情况下进行复杂的手术。有时，他甚至不认识手术室里与他并肩工作的所有人。我径直走进去，这里本该是一个安静的地方，人们不会问太多问题，他们本该知道自己在做什么，然后你只需
proceed, and then when something goes wrong, you'd be like, you know, why didn't ask a lot of questions, they're just supposed to know what they're doing, and then you just proceed, and then when something goes wrong, you'd be like, you know, why didn't you guys know what the hell you were doing? And either, you know, that kind of ridiculous lack of preparation was the typical story. Atul, like Johns Hopkins Physician Peter Pronevost, became interested early in his career
继续进行，当事情出错时，你会觉得，你知道的，为什么你们不问多一点问题，你们本来就该知道自己在搞什么鬼，然后你只能硬着头皮继续，结果出事的时候，你就会想，你知道的，为什么你们这帮家伙连自己在做什么都不知道？无论如何，那种荒谬的缺乏准备是典型的故事。阿图尔和约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的医生彼得·普罗诺沃斯特一样，在他的职业生涯早期就开始对
in the routines and assumptions embedded in medicine. How much was the success of a surgeon about talent and training? How much of it was about having strong procedures and teamwork? Otto began to look for answers to those questions. I'd done a study with several other researchers while I was in my training where I got to look at data from a team that had gathered information from hospitals across Utah and Colorado, and they were looking at people who had a major complication or death during a hospital admission. And I found two things in examining the data. Two thirds of the patients who had a major disability or death as a bad outcome from their care were surgical patients. And furthermore, I found at least two thirds of those patients turned out to have died
医学中蕴含的常规和假设产生兴趣。外科医生的成功有多少取决于天赋和培训？又有多少取决于拥有强大的规程和团队合作？奥托开始寻找这些问题的答案。我在接受培训时曾与几位其他研究人员做过一项研究，当时我得以查看来自一个团队的数据，该团队收集了犹他州和科罗拉多州各大医院的信息，他们研究的是在住院期间出现重大并发症或死亡的患者。在检查数据时，我发现了两件事。在因治疗护理产生不良结果而导致重大残疾或死亡的患者中，三分之二都是外科患者。此外，我发现其中至少有三分之二的患者最终死于
from a problem where we had the answer but didn't execute on it. In fact, it was a very tiny percentage of patients who had a major disability or death that was due to a problem that we hadn't discovered the answer for. It was mostly a problem of lack of execution. People were suffering and in some cases dying because surgical teams were making preventable errors overlooking basic steps that could make an operation safer. Otto realized that the unsexy task of developing better surgical procedures was actually the
我们其实知道答案但却没有执行好的问题。事实上，导致重大残疾或死亡的患者中，只有极小一部分是因为我们还没有找到答案的问题。这主要是缺乏执行力的问题。人们正在遭受痛苦，在某些情况下甚至正在死亡，因为手术团队正在犯下可避免的错误，忽视了可以使手术更安全的基本步骤。奥托意识到，开发更好外科手术程序这项看似平淡无奇的任务，实际上是他所能做的
most important work he could do. The volume of surgery had exploded around the world as people lived longer to more than 300 million operations worldwide, one for every 20, 22 or so human beings. But the death rates for 10 to 100 times higher than in childbirth. So that meant that we needed to look at this as a public health problem. Otto started looking more deeply at the problem. He was intrigued by the study Peter Pronevost had conducted in Michigan. Peter had found that using a checklist could dramatically reduce catheter infections. Otto decided to develop a checklist for surgical teams.
最重要的工作。随着人们寿命的延长，全球的手术量呈爆炸式增长，全球每年进行超过3.00万台手术，大约每20、22个人中就有一台。但死亡率却是分娩时的10到100倍。这意味着我们需要将此视为一个公共卫生问题。奥托开始更深入地研究这个问题。他对彼得·普罗诺沃斯特在密歇根州进行的研究所吸引。彼得发现，使用核对表可以显着减少导管感染。奥托决定为手术团队开发一份核对表。
We worked with a variety of teams, experts in anesthesia, infectious disease, surgery, nursing, and so on. He also went to Seattle to meet with airline safety experts at Boeing. And one of the key points that the Boeing folks emphasize to us is that it has to fit into the workflow and cannot be a distraction from the core things you're doing and make matters worse.
我们与各种团队合作，包括麻醉、传染病、外科、护理等方面的专家。他还前往西雅图，与波音公司的航空安全专家会面。波音公司的人向我们强调的关键点之一是，它必须融入工作流程，不能分散你对核心事情的注意力，从而使情况变得更糟。
So if you're launching a rocket into space, you have all the time in the world. You get one shot at this thing, right? Whereas we do 50 million operations per year in the United States. We have a lot of people we have to take care of. And if we only get through half of them, we have a whole lot of people who end up being harmed along the way. So we set some terms around this. We have two minutes total for a check before the patients put to sleep, a check before the
因此，如果你要将火箭发射到太空，你有的是时间。这件事你只有一次机会，对吧？然而在美国，我们每年要进行5000万台手术。我们要照顾很多人。如果我们只能完成一半，那我们在过程中就会伤害到相当多的人。因此，我们在周围设定了一些期限。在患者被麻醉前，我们总共有两分钟的时间进行检查；在
incisions made and a check before the person leaves the room. And then can we run through it in such a way that you're identifying the killer items, you want to chunk it because the brain can only handle five to nine items at a time and so we had to chunk it into components that allow people to you know run through it in a reasonable way while having a potentially emergency patient on the table in front of you. Once he had a basic checklist in hand it was time to test it out. Surgical teams in eight cities around the world agreed to give it a try.
切口作出前进行检查；以及在患者离开房间前进行检查。然后，我们能否以这样一种方式贯穿始终：你能够识别出那些致命的关键项？你必须把它分块，因为大脑一次只能处理五到九个信息项，所以我们必须把它分成若干部分，让人们能够在有潜在急诊患者躺在面前的情况下，以合理的方式完成它。一旦他手头有了基本的核对表，就是测试它的时候了。全球八个城市的手术团队同意试用它。
Rural Tanzania, a city hospital in Delhi to some of the wealthiest places. University of Washington Medical Center in Seattle, St. Mary's Hospital in London, Toronto General Hospital, and in every hospital you had a reduction in complications, the average reduction in complications was 35%, the reduction in deaths was 47%. A 47% reduction in deaths, checklists, it seemed, could be as powerful in a surgical setting as they were in reducing catheter infections.
坦桑尼亚的农村、德里的一家城市医院，甚至是一些最富裕的地方。西雅图的华盛顿大学医学中心、伦敦的圣玛丽医院、多伦多全科医院，在每一家医院，并发症都有所减少，并发症平均减少了35%，死亡人数减少了47%。死亡人数减少了47%，核对表在手术环境中似乎和在减少导管感染方面一样强大。
Since auto-pul published those findings, checklists have become a standard part of surgeries in hospitals around the world, including at the hospital, where Attul works. Operating rooms at Brigham & Women's Hospital in Boston are crowded and busy places. You have lots of surgical equipment and monitors and lots of people in motion.
自从阿图尔发表这些发现以来，核对表已成为全球医院手术的标准部分，包括阿图尔工作的医院。波士顿布莱根妇女医院的手术室拥挤而繁忙。里面有许多手术设备和监视器，还有许多走动的人。
Atul Gawande and a group of colleagues are preparing to perform a surgery. Their patient is a woman named Heather Parsons. They're reviewing Heather's medical history and the plan for her surgery. One member of the team asks Heather to confirm the procedure they're about to perform. Heather and the team agree that they're going to do a partial thyroid ectomy on the right side of her body. It can be a little hard to hear everything here. Microphones are not very easy to sterilize, and since infection control is a major concern, we had to record some distance from the action.
阿图尔·加万德和一群同事正准备做手术。他们的病人是一位名叫海瑟·帕尔森的女士。他们正在审查海瑟的病史和手术计划。团队的一名成员请海瑟确认他们即将进行的手术。海瑟和团队一致同意，他们将在她身体的右侧进行部分甲状腺切除术。这里的一切可能有点难以听清。麦克风不是很容易消毒，由于感染控制是一个主要问题，我们不得不记录一些离手术动作较远的音频。
The team goes over concerns they had in the lead up to the surgery, and they tell Heather how they plan to address those concerns. Then, they begin anesthesia. So I want you to breathe out. I know I tell you so I want you to breathe out. Breathe in. Okay, so breathe out.
团队讨论了他们在手术前遇到的担忧，并告诉海瑟他们计划如何解决这些担忧。然后，他们开始麻醉。所以我要你呼气。我知道我告诉过你，所以我要你呼气。吸气。好的，呼气。
Open wide. Breathe in. And then do it. After Heather goes to sleep, the team formally begins their surgical safety checklist. They again review her full name, date of birth, allergies, and the plan for the surgery. And then they do something that might not occur to those of us who've never watched a surgery. They do introductions.
嘴巴张大。吸气。然后做这个。海瑟入睡后，团队正式开始他们的手术安全核对表。他们再次核对她的全名、出生日期、过敏史以及手术计划。然后他们做了一件从未看过手术的我们可能不会想到的事。他们做自我介绍。
Orgathering news, please just something. Brad, surgical pack. They confirm that they have all the equipment they need and they double-check that there are no other medical concerns that need to be addressed. Then, with George Michael's song Faith in the background, they begin the surgery. It might seem obvious that surgical teams should run through a routine like this. Of course, each person should know the name of everyone else on the team. Of course, everyone needs to be on the same page about the surgery they're performing and the potential risks.
或者收集新闻，请随便做点什么。布拉德，手术包。他们确认拥有所需的所有设备，并仔细检查没有其他需要解决的医疗问题。然后，在乔治·迈克尔的歌曲《信仰》的背景音乐中，他们开始手术。手术团队应该经历这样一套常规程序，这似乎是显而易见的。当然，每个人都应该知道团队中其他所有人的名字。当然，每个人都需要就他们正在进行的手术以及潜在风险达成共识。
But until checklist became a rule, these obvious things weren't always put into practice. Atul says it's worth remembering that checklists have not been universally successful. They only work if medical teams tailor them to their own needs and their own local cultures. When we ask people for their copies of the checklist, looking at 100 checklists, virtually every one of them has been changed and customized in some way that they've done locally. And I've seen checklists that take our 19 items and made them more than 80 items. An administration had taken over the control of the checklists. They piled all these things on and then everybody ignored,
但在核对表成为一条规则之前，这些显而易见的事情并不总是付诸实践。阿图尔说，值得记住的是，核对表并未在普遍意义上取得成功。只有当医疗团队根据自身需求和当地文化对其进行定制时，它们才有效。当我们向人们索要他们的核对表副本时，通过查看100份核对表，几乎每一份都在当地以某种方式进行了修改和定制。我见过将我们的19个项目增加到80多个项目的核对表。行政部门接管了核对表的控制权。他们把所有这些东西都堆上去，然后每个人都忽视了
started ignoring them because you just couldn't make it work in a day where you had to get through taking care of the patients. One big cautionary tale he says is how the surgical checklist was rolled out in Canada. So in Canada and Ottawa, they deployed it by making it a law. You have to do this in the hospital, and the hospitals then would sign off that they followed the law, and they got a 0% improvement in death, because there wasn't an actual implementation program. Contrast this to what happened in South Carolina. The State's Hospital Association reached out to Atul to ask him for his help in launching a surgical checklist initiative. Atul says South Carolina's program, unlike Canada's, was voluntary. There was a lengthy process to make sure teams at each
开始忽略它们，因为在必须照顾患者的一天里，你根本无法让它发挥作用。他说，一个重大的前车之鉴是手术核对表在加拿大的推广方式。因此在加拿大渥太华，他们通过立法来推广它。你必须在医院里这样做，然后医院会签署他们遵守了法律，但死亡率却改善了0%，因为没有实际的实施计划。将其与南卡罗来纳州发生的情况进行对比。该州的医院协会联系阿图尔，请求他协助发起一项手术核对表倡议。阿图尔说，南卡罗来纳州的项目与加拿大不同，是自愿的。经过了一个漫长的过程，以确保每个
hospital understood the point of the checklist. They were encouraged to change it, make it their own. There was also a game plan to deal with hospital politics. Expect you're going to have some surgeons who say this isn't such a great idea. I don't want to do it. And we had a strategy for approaching those folks, which is simply to go in and see them one on one, and just ask, will you help? And more often than not, people will.
医院的团队都理解核对表的意义。他们被鼓励去改变它，把它变成他们自己的。还有一个应对医院政治的计划。预计会有一些外科医生说这不是个好主意。我不想这么做。我们有一个接近这些人的策略，那就是直接进去和他们一对一地谈，然后只问一句：你愿意帮忙吗？通常情况下，人们都会答应。
In the end, about 25% of South Carolina's hospitals, which take care of 40% of the state's population, took part in the checklist effort. Atul says those hospitals saw a 22% reduction in patient deaths. And that was as many lives saved as would have died in car accidents in that population. These results, the first large scale study of surgical checklist use in a general patient population were recently published in the journal Annals of Medicine. Atul has spent a lot of time thinking about checklist.
最终，南卡罗来纳州大约25%的医院（服务于该州40%的人口）参与了核对表工作。阿图尔说，这些医院的患者死亡率下降了22%。这挽救的生命数量相当于该群岛人群中死于车祸的人数。这些结果是针对普通患者群体的手术核对表使用的首次大规模研究，最近发表在《内科学年鉴》杂志上。阿图尔花了很多时间思考核对表。
Yes, they can reduce deaths and they can reduce hospital infections, but they can also do something else that's surprising. They can generate a feeling of teamwork and shared purpose. Operating rooms are often people who are getting together at the start of a day as a completely new team. You will have people coming together in combinations getting together at the start of a day as a completely new team. You will have people coming together in combinations that sometimes have never really worked together before or haven't worked together in a long time.
是的，它们可以减少死亡和医院感染，但它们还能产生另一种令人惊讶的效果。它们可以营造一种团队合作和共同目标感。手术室里的人通常在一天开始时聚集在一起，组成一个全新的团队。你会看到一些组合在一起的人，
The nurse on duty for the day, the anesthesiologist on duty for the day, a resident participating. And so you have to quickly make that team gel in Coless. The act of people speaking up and just hearing themselves say their name in the room, studies have shown that when people have had that chance to introduce themselves, they're much more likely to speak up later. And that's what we're now recognizing is that when you just stand and watch a team that has used the checklist, there is much more likelihood that people will raise questions, feel comfortable saying, hmm, I don't quite understand why XYZ is happening. And in general, you see much more equality of voices in the room.
当班的护士，当班的麻醉师，参与其中的住院医师。因此，你必须迅速让这个团队凝聚成形。人们大声发言、听到自己在房间里说出自己名字的行为，研究表明，当人们有机会自我介绍时，他们随后更有可能大声发言。这就是我们现在所认识到的：当你站在一旁观看一个使用过核对表的团队时，人们提出问题、感到舒适地说“嗯，我不太明白为什么会发生某某情况”的可能性要大得多。总的来说，你会发现房间里有更多平等的声音。
You have as much talking to be likely from a nurse, a surgeon, and an anesthesiologist, rather than one or another dominating. Is it, is the idea of the checklist you can basically do away with the expert now? In other words, if you can come up with a list of things to do, can I be the surgeon that you are or the pilot that flies Boeing planes? Yeah, no. Absolutely not. Oh, done.
你更有可能听到护士、外科医生和麻醉师的声音，而不是某一个人占主导地位。核对表的理念是，你现在基本上可以取代专家了吗？换句话说，如果你能列出一张要做的事情的清单，我能成为你这样的外科医生，或是驾驶波音飞机的飞行员吗？是的，不。绝对不行。哦，做完了。
Right? So, one of the amazing things that just looking at these checklists is they're made for experts use. They're not an algorithm. They're not a recipe for flying a plane. They are the, you know, here in this moment of the five most common ways that things go wrong. It's put into a very professional, terse language.
对吧？所以，看这些核对表最神奇的事情之一就是，它们是为专家使用而制作的。它们不是算法。它们不是驾驶飞机的处方。它们是，你知道的，此时此刻最常出错的五种情况。它被写成了一种非常专业、简练的语言。
You know, it's almost like one word or two words, check. Do you have this? Have you got that? Check. And then you move on. It's aimed to be a supplement to your brain, both activating it and advancing it. And that's, to me, some of the coolest aspects of it, because this is what enables a professional to function at this incredible level of performance.
你知道，几乎就像一两个词，核对。你有这个吗？你拿到那个了吗？核对。然后你继续。它的目的是作为你大脑的补充，既能激活它又能推进它。对我来说，这是它最酷的一些方面，因为这正是让专业人员能够以这种令人难以置信的表现水平运转的原因。
There are a million ways that things can go wrong, but there is a recipe for being ready for how to handle it. Is everybody understand why you're here, what the background medical issues are of this person? Do we all understand what each other's roles are? Do we know how long the case will take? Are we ready for the unexpected? And by doing that, that's putting you in an entirely different place. It's a place that he says doesn't have to be reserved only for doctors or pilots or people in high stress jobs. At all things, we could all benefit from checklist. The reasons checklist for fascinating me is that they're the oldest, most simple system human beings have invented for dealing with the limitations of our brain
事情出错的方式有一百万种，但有一套应对如何处理它的准备处方。每个人都明白你们为什么来这里、这个人的背景医疗问题是什么吗？我们都明白彼此的角色吗？我们知道病例需要多长时间吗？我们为意料之外的事情做好准备了吗？通过这样做，这将把你带到一个完全不同的地方。这是一个他说不必只留给医生、飞行员或高压工作人群的地方。阿图尔认为，我们所有人都可以从核对表中受益。核对表让我着迷的原因在于，它们是人类为应对大脑局限性而发明的
and also the limitations of working together as a team. I got to talk about this on the Cal Bear report. Americans don't need checklists, we f***ing let. Okay. All right, check one. Show up to work. Two, be American. Okay.
以及作为团队合作的局限性，最古老、最简单的系统。我在《科尔报告》上谈过这件事。美国人不需要核对表，我们TMD会放任自流。好吧。好吧，核对一。去上班。二，做一个美国人。好吧。
And greatest workers in the world. That's so cool, I get to be American. Okay. And greatest workers in the world. That's so cool, I get to go on. Do you use checklist? So we do use a checklist. I finally began using a checklist in the last couple of years. What do you do with a checklist? Well, it turned out one of the main reason you wanted me on was then to talk about you
世界上最伟大的工人。太酷了，我成了美国人。好吧。继续前进。你使用核对表吗？我们确实在使用核对表。在过去几年里，我终于开始使用核对表了。你用核对表做什么？好吧，事实证明，你想让我上节目的主要原因之一就是讨论你
said, hey, is there a checklist for what we do? Because this drives me crazy. Every day, we have planned out the whole show, then around three o'clock, there'll be some breaking news thing, and you have to completely remake the jokes. And it always ends up falling apart, and there are mistakes left and right because we're remaking the show half the time on the fly. How would we have a checklist for breaking news comedy?
说过，“嘿，我们做的事情有核对表吗？因为这把我快逼疯了。”每天我们都把整个节目计划好，然后到三点左右，会有一些突发新闻，你必须完全重新编写笑话。结果总是弄得一团糟，左右都是错误，因为我们有一半时间都在现场临时重新制作节目。我们怎么能为突发新闻喜剧制定核对表呢？
And it's totally doable. You can look at what happens every time, what are the things that go wrong, and how can you have a series of checks so you're not making the same mistakes over and over and over again. Surgeon, pilots, and parents often have to raise to get things done. The more we rush, the easier it becomes to trip over something and take a fall. Checklists won't necessarily solve all problems of modern living.
这完全是可行的。你可以看看每次发生的事情，什么地方出错了，以及如何拥有一系列核对，这样你就不会一遍又一遍地犯同样的错误。外科医生、飞行员和父母经常不得不匆忙完成工作。我们越匆忙，就越容易被某些东西绊倒并摔倒。核对表不一定能解决现代生活中的所有问题。
Airplanes and space shuttles will still crash, despite elaborate checklists. Surgeries will still go wrong, even when a team takes the time to anticipate the risks. Merely setting up checklists won't mean that we follow them. We can set up a calendar alert, reminding us of a 5pm project deadline, and then procrastinate all the way until 445, before we try to get it done. Checklists can also be so long and complicated that they become self-defeating. You can draw up a comprehensive list before heading to the supermarket and then come home and find you forgot to get the coffee.
尽管有精心制作的核对表，飞机和航天飞机仍然会坠毁。即使团队花时间预测风险，手术仍然会出错。仅仅建立核对表并不意味着我们会遵循它们。我们可以设置一个日历提醒，提醒我们下午5点项目截止，然后一直拖延到4点45分，才试图去完成它。核对表也可能太长太复杂，以至于适得其反。你在去超市之前可以拟定一份详尽的清单，结果回家后发现忘了买咖啡。
But what checklists do accomplish is they get us to focus on things that are most likely to trip us up. Over time, preventing the most common errors will have the biggest impact on our lives. Perhaps most important, checklists are one of humanity's oldest tools to combat our blind spots and our arrogance. The humble checklist reminds us of the importance of humility, because, in the end, we're only human. Since this episode came out last fall, Atul and his team published a large study on checklists in rural India. They wanted to see if checklists could prevent deaths of mothers and newborns.
但核对表所实现的是，它们让我们专注于最容易让我们绊倒的事情。随着时间的推移，防止最常见的错误将对我们的生活产生最大的影响。也许最重要的是，核对表是人类对抗盲点和傲慢的最古老工具之一。卑微的核对表提醒我们谦逊的重要性，因为归根结底，我们只是凡人。自从去年秋天这一集播出以来，阿图尔和他的团队在印度农村发表了一项关于核对表的大型研究。他们想看看核对表是否能防止母亲和新生儿的死亡。
They found that checklists didn't change mortality rates, in part because they weren't enough highly-scaled healthcare providers and because of inadequate access to basic medical supplies such as running water and clean towels. Atold says this finding reinforces the idea that checklists aren't a panacea for all problems in a complicated healthcare system. This week's episode was produced by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Jennifer Schmidt, Raina Cohen, Parts Cha, Thomas Liu, Laura Quarelle and Aditi Bandlamudi. We had original music composed by Rampti and Arableui. Our Ransang heroes this week are Atul Gawande's colleagues Debra O'Neil, Tania Palethusain,
他们发现核对表并没有改变死亡率，部分原因是没有足够的高素质医疗保健提供者，并且由于缺乏流水和干净毛巾等基本医疗用品。阿图尔说，这一发现强化了这样一个观点：核对表并不是解决复杂医疗体系中所有问题的灵丹妙药。本期节目由塔拉·博伊尔制作。我们的团队包括珍妮弗·施密特、雷娜·科恩、帕茨·查、托马斯·刘、劳拉·夸雷尔和阿迪蒂·班德拉穆迪。我们的原创音乐由兰普蒂和阿拉布鲁伊创作。我们这周的幕后英雄是阿图尔·加万德的同事黛布拉·奥尼尔、塔尼亚·帕莱胡森、
Laurie Shrath, Angel Laiala and Samuel Kim. Figuring out how to get audio from Atolennis colleagues and surgery was not easy. There were all kinds of hurdles around infection control and patient privacy. Deborah, Tania and Laurie spent many hours working to overcome those hurdles. They also managed to carve out time in a busy surgeon's schedule for not one,
劳瑞·施拉特、安吉尔·莱拉和塞缪尔·金。弄清如何从阿图尔及其同事的手术中获取音频并不容易。关于感染控制和患者隐私存在各种各样的障碍。黛布拉、塔尼亚和劳瑞花了许多时间来克服这些障碍。他们还在忙碌的外科医生日程中设法挤出时间，进行了不止一次，
but two interviews. Angel and Sam got the sound you heard from the operating room at Brigham and Women's Hospital. Many thanks to all of you. You can find more of our reporting on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode of the show, one request. Please make your own checklist of all the friends you think might enjoy hidden brain and share the show with them. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. with him. I'm Shankar Vitantum, see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
而是两次采访。安吉尔和萨姆获取了你在布莱根妇女医院手术室听到声音。非常感谢你们所有人。你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们的更多报道。如果你喜欢这一集的节目，有一个请求。请为你认为可能喜欢《隐藏的大脑》的所有朋友制作你自己的核对表，并与他们分享这个节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。和他分享。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，下周见。本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。